good day everyone and Happy New Year I'm
Jack Van Horn from the University of
Southern California and I'd like to
welcome you to the next webinar on big
data to knowledge guide to the
fundamentals of data science we're
absolutely delighted to have dr. Ian
Foster from the University of Chicago
and Argonne National Laboratories here
to discuss why the cloud matters for
data science dr. Foster is a
well-regarded computer scientist based
at the University of Chicago where he is
a professor of computer science and he's
also the director of data science in the
data science and learning division and
distinguished fellow at Argonne National
Laboratory he received his bachelor's
degree from the University of Canterbury
in New Zealand and his PhD from Imperial
College in London England both for
computer science and he is well known
for his work on the developments of grid
computing of the globus network of how
to move data around efficiently on the
Internet and his work involves
developing tools and techniques which
allow people to use high-performance
computing technologies to do
quantitative things new and easily we
really like to welcome dr. Foster and
I'd like to welcome you though the
audience to text in and submit your
questions via the little questions
submission system here and I will work
to gather those up and ask them on your
behalf of dr. Foster towards the end of
the hour without further ado though I'd
like to turn the webinar over to dr.
foster to tell us why the cloud matters
for data science Ian the stage is yours
thank you jack good morning good
afternoon for those on the East Coast
thanks for joining so what I want to do
today is talk to you about cloud and
hopefully tell you a few things that you
don't know about it and they'll give you
a idea of why it is important I think a
very you know fundamentally
transformative technology that we should
all the
deeply familiar with then and in some
cases working out how to apply it in our
science so my first let's me my first
slide here the quotes are a few
interesting assertions I guess by the
Gartner group about cloud computing this
is from a fairly recent report of theirs
and it has some interesting observations
you know the first bullet there asserts
that your mini large enterprises will be
moving to largely cloud only strategies
for new IT in other words they'll be
deploying new data systems computing
systems and so forth not in house but on
resources provided by companies like
Amazon or Google or Microsoft that
increasingly those applications are
going to be mission-critical that
they're going to be moving getting more
text specific moving towards using
container rather than virtual machines
to host things and we'll say a little a
little bit about that later that though
increasingly being using AI technologies
learning and data science technologies
that will increasingly be clower posture
and starting to use a technology called
cloud near the native service computing
which I'll say a bit more about as well
because I think it's significant and
when we think about how we might create
data science applications that we intend
to scale to to large numbers of users so
let's so that's sort of just by way of
background now let's move on and and
spend a bit of time talking about what
cloud computing is and and how one might
be able to use it so you know first of
all perhaps though to spend a minute
saying well why is it that cloud
computing is able to do all these
wonderful thing is why is it that people
at least in enterprises
looking so seriously at running large
and complex applications on cloud
computing well first of all it's you
know due to caught the economies of
scale that are inherent in the extremely
large deployments that are operated by a
cloud provider service I think is a a
Google machine room I think near Chicago
but you know there are many of these
warehouse scale computing systems being
operated by a growing number of
companies and it's just it's it in a
fascinating picture you can see the
enormous sizes that they are able to
operate and and therefore the and that
translates into suddenly issues of
scalability economies of scale in terms
of operations also reliability and and
less obviously perhaps also has
implications for things like security
you've got very dedicated professional
staff operating and ensuring the
security of this sort of system so
arguably cloud computing systems are
more secure than whatever might be
operated by your home institution where
people use the word cloud or just
mentioned briefly to refer to a variety
of different technologies you'll hear
people talking about private clouds or
academic or community clouds these tend
to be clusters operated inside a machine
room at an institution running certain
software that will allow access to
certain storage models and computing
models but mostly I'm going to be
talking today about public cloud which
is the sorts of systems that I just
showed you a picture of and I think
that's an important distinction public
cloud tends to have a far richer set of
services and it's those services that I
think would be part of the what makes
cloud computing exciting
um so that lets in a minute now talking
about what the cloud is so in my view
you can think of cloud computing as
providing three different capabilities
or sets of capabilities to users one
there - where probably many of us are
familiar with is is you can think of the
cloud as a virtual computer it's
something that lets you run a virtual
machine or store a file there are many
virtual machines for many files but
doing so just the things you do on your
on your workstation or institutional
computer about doing it in the machine
room like the one that I just showed you
and of course that has a certain
benefits we we can for example deploy a
virtual machine and run an application
that perhaps requires more resources
that we have available locally perhaps
that your users are specialized hardware
device like a graphical processing unit
GPU that we don't have available locally
but it's really not fundamentally
different from what we do on our
ordinary everyday computing the second
model of cloud computing is as what you
might call a lab assistant um you know I
a it's a set of software services that
those things that you know we could do
ourselves locally but is perhaps more
useful to do or more efficient to do we
all make use of the sort of software as
a service side of cloud computing every
day if we use a Google Docs or Google
Mail or some travel planning service and
so on and so forth and there are you
know a growing number also of more
scientific software as a service
offerings a bailable will cover some of
those a bit locally a bit later and then
thirdly and this is perhaps the most
interesting part of cloud computing
is it's it's increasingly as a
programming platform it's a set of
platform services and we'll go through
what some of those are a little bit
later with very rich and powerful
platform services that we can use to
build our own very interesting
applications often more quickly more
reliably more securely than we might be
able to do if we built them locally and
we might run those applications on the
cloud itself as I sort of show in the
bottom lower right here or we might
build applications that run on on our in
our own lab but that happen to use some
of these platform services to for
example manage workflows or store the
results of computations and those hybrid
sorts of things are often very
interesting now so here's just to give
you an idea of when I say that there's a
lot of platform services this is a a
figure that shows the platform services
provided by one particular cloud vendor
Amazon Web Services and I won't go
through them here in any detail but
you'll certainly you'll get the idea
that there's a lot of them you'll see
they cover topics like compute and
storage certainly but also other areas
like content delivery workflow
management notification services and
monitoring okay this is only a subset of
all the services that Amazon provides
and people were starting to use these
sorts of services to write some very
interesting data science applications
and I may have time to say a bit about
those later and you know just one thing
that this emergence of this new
programming platform if you like has
spurred is an incredible variety
of software-as-a-service capabilities so
these this is a actually quite an old
slide it's six years old the Bessemer
Venture Capital firm hasn't created a
new version of it recently at least not
in this format but now this was a you
know their attempt to capture as they
said the top 300 companies that were
providing various forms of software as a
service or platform as a service
capabilities to to enterprises of course
a few of these are relevant to science
most of them are not
hopefully I believe we're going to see
an emergence of more scientifically
focused software and platform as a
service offerings in the in the coming
years now I mentioned in the abstract
for the tutorial for the for this
lecture and I'll mention here myself and
my colleague Dennis Ken and recently
produced a book on cloud computing the
science and engineering that really goes
far more deeply than I can and this in
this hour or so into this question of
what cloud computing is and how it can
be used for science and engineering so
I'm going to use a variety of components
from that book as I proceed from the
rest of this lecture and I should
emphasize that this is not just a a bad
sales job you can buy this book but the
contents are all also all entirely
online at cloud for science all so
you're able to enjoy it without some
purchasing the book although it does
make a nice present for your for your
family and so forth anyway so let me
just show you what goes into the online
system because it has a couple of
interesting features so of course we've
got the the contents of the book and you
know available and something that looks
quite pleasant and
see the sort of what the topics we cover
and these are the topics that I'm going
to review very briefly in this in this
lecture how you use the cloud as a
platform sorry as a virtual computer how
you manage data in the cloud how you can
compute in the cloud and then how you
use the cloud as platform how you may
the services that are available for
things like data analytic streaming
machine learning I'll say a bit about
something called the globus research
data management platform which is cloud
hosted and is often used in science I
will talk today but the book does talk a
bit about how to build your own cloud
you know how to configure a cluster of
your own to run some of these data and
management and computing management
services and there's also I won't also
talk today about security and privacy
but there's a lot of material in the
book on that and of course that's a very
important topic for many purposes so
that's a that's the content of the book
the other interesting thing here and I'd
really like to just convey it to you
briefly is we have a set of Jupiter
notebooks hopefully many of you are
familiar with Jupiter you know a
web-based interactive computing
environment so we have some 23 I think
it is Jupiter notebooks that allow you
to you know try will observe or
experiment with develop applications
using the the various technologies that
are described in this book and yeah this
is what a jupiter notebook looks like
for those of you who are not familiar
with it here we're using it to run
Python we use Python really for all of
the examples in the book pretty much and
you know just free briefly Jupiter
notebook has a series of cells each of
which contain Python code and you can
run these cells in lot online you know
using using your web browser and you
create and lock in line graphics or as
we often do manipulate some
yeah and access cloud computing services
to do things like retrieve data store
data or run computing and so forth okay
so let me just spend a few minutes now
talking about some of the capabilities
that you're going to get from cloud
computing at the infrastructure level
the cloud is virtual computer so what
does your desktop computer provide to
you it provides computing and storage I
mean there's other things because of
course the software that it runs but
computing and storage are the two
fundamental capabilities and similarly
cloud computing providers offer a
actually a very rich set of storage as a
service options and these implementers
will show here are a variety of
different storage models there's
certainly filesystem models so that you
can read and write files just as you
would on your desktop machine but there
are also other important storage models
offered as well so object storage it's
probably the most was the first hard
storage service provided by Amazon so
quite a few years ago now and there's
one of the most popular it's important
it's important related relates to the
fact that it's a highly scalable
reliable and and relatively inexpensive
compared to compared to some of the
others but as well as object storage
which we'll say more about in a minute
there's you know they provide relational
database services new at no SQL database
services graph database services
warehouse analytic services and so forth
what I'm showing here in terms of each
of these columns is what offerings each
of the three major cloud vendors
provides Amazon Google and Azure and
you'll see that they they all have often
very similar sometimes rather different
versions of these capabilities so you
know it's not unusual now to see people
building data analytics services that
maintain the data that's being
manipulated in an object store or
relational data service you compute on
the data on cloud and then write results
back to two other cloud services before
the computing and we'll see examples of
that in a second a few words about some
objects the object storage model the
basic idea is similar across all systems
your storage universe is divided up into
buckets called sometimes that will
containers sometimes called buckets and
within a bucket you can place often very
large numbers of objects and the storage
system the cloud service team provides
application programming interfaces and
other methods for putting things into
containers for retrieving them taken
from containers for associating
attributes with with containers and so
forth so well we'll see an example of
that in a minute but yeah one one other
thing we're showing here is that one
thing that containers objects stores
commonly support is is some form of
versioning which can be important of
course if you are concerned about
reproducible science and we know to
track changes to your data over time so
it's the object model to show briefly
how it is realized by in in one
particular cloud service Amazon and I
use this example really to also convey
another notion which is that most of
these services that cloud providers
offer support both web interfaces for
you know interactive use so at the top
here I'm creating a new bucket called
plan for science you'll see that I get a
mass where I want to create it and I can
place it there are different data
centers often operated by cloud
providers and depending on where I think
most of the accesses will come when they
make places in one location or another
and of course I've been out to the user
web interface is often a very nice way
of manipulating things but then
typically there are application
programming interfaces in software
development kits that allow me to do
anything I can do with a web interface
and often more programmatically so I'm
down the bottom I've got some Python
code that's basically doing the same
thing as I just showed here first of all
I delete the bucket I just created with
the rest with the with the web interface
and then I create it specifying that I
want it located in the US standing
region and then I put a knob put an
object into that newly created bucket so
you can do some amazingly sophisticated
things using fairly simple Python code
so so that's it
we won't I won't see more about storage
there are some other wonderful storage
services let me say a bit about
computing in the cloud now so you know
sort of just summarize some of the key
concepts by showing the table of
contents from the online book so
computing as a service at the most
fundamental level is offered typically
in the in the form of either virtual
machines or containers and I'll say more
about the difference between those in a
minute
server loss computing I'll also say more
about a little bit further on but you
know each cloud service offers
mechanisms that allow you to create
virtual machines create one instance of
a virtual machine
10/100/1000 configured with whatever
software you want and then there are
various also services that let you
manage large numbers of such virtual
machines for example you may run
MapReduce computations across them you
might run a define a computing graph or
workflow that runs on them you can also
run message passing interface
computations across them the cloud
systems don't tend to offer the ultra
high-speed communication interfaces that
might be required for high performance
computing style parallels and at very
large scales but they seem to do
reasonably well up to at least a few
hundred nodes and many cases which is
often all that one needs for ones for
ones
scientific applications and issue
dealing with extremely large scale
simulations so these are some of the
concepts I think you'll service is sort
of special and we'll come back to that
but the rest of them are the sorts of
things that you might reasonably do on
your own local computing server
computing system a little bit about
virtual machines versus containers
perhaps many of you are familiar with
the distinctions here you know a
container is in some sense a more
lightweight version of a virtual machine
additional machine forces something that
lets you run a particular application in
a particular set of libraries in a
particular operating system on a
computer without having to you know have
that computer dedicated to that through
that operating system so if your
software is designed to run on a
particular version of Linux
or a particular version of Windows you
can stand up a virtual machine with that
software including the operating system
deployed and ready to go and no
containers work in a similar fashion
except the they organize themselves
slightly differently internally and
there's the table at the bottom you know
points out new containers I be
increasingly used for well for many
things but including data science
because they're more lightweight they
can be deployed very rapidly they can be
created and destroyed rapidly and for
various reasons they are quite portable
from one cloud cloud to another thanks
to technologies like docker and
singularity which I won't say more about
so just to point out that as with
storage so with computing the cloud
providers offer web interfaces that let
you you know start and manage instances
so here I am looking at Amazon compute
virtual machine interface and you can
see I've got well three virtual machine
instances - a stocked one is running on
bankers in the middle of initializing
and I could launch additional ones if I
wanted so this or the click of a button
like them to create a new computing
system and of course if I don't want to
click buttons then as a storage I can
also create instances using for example
a Python API so down the bottom here I'm
creating one instance of a particular
type micro types race not very powerful
instance using a specified virtual
machine image in the US West region they
could also be creating a thousand
instances of very powerful computers
using the same same way
um so give you a feeling for what term
sorts of things that you can do with
these capabilities so here's a this is a
pipeline developed by a group at Chicago
working with people at USC and ISD and
in Seattle so it's concerned with so
what they wanted to do was I won't go
into the technical details but run a
computational process that would find
potential transcript transcription
factor binding sites within large
amounts of DNA's seek data from encode
and the pipeline involved running
various popular applications snap a
liner if seek tool a couple of different
footprints finding applications then
running this over actually large amounts
you know terabytes of data well actually
it's more tens of gigabytes of data but
producing along the way terabytes of
data from the as a recite effect of the
computation so this is something that
would be pretty hard to run on one's
desktop or even you know in a typical
lab but because we use Amazon Web
Services we can fire this up on many
multi core nodes and run the whole thing
in a couple of hours I think using in
the Space Center before no doubt 714 Oh
towers during computation and then the
results the data come is it retrieved
from the encode system it's the results
are eventually deploy that's onto Amazon
storage so isn't it typical many
scientific applications we are using a
mix of cloud and R on cloud
computing resources to do what we want
to do I just mentioned very briefly that
for those in the scientific space who
are interested in working with cloud
computing but don't want to use public
cloud resources
for a number of academic cloud providers
that one can work with perhaps the most
accessible is Jetstream this operate
operated by the National Science
Foundation or operated for the National
Science Foundation by the University of
Indiana
so Jetstream cloud org you can get there
and request I think a start-up account
quite easily and then you can do the
sorts of things I've been showing
already you know create a virtual
machine create containers store data and
so on and so forth my research group of
Chicago uses this quite a bit and they
find it very very easy to work with okay
so that's some a few words about the
cloud as a virtual computer a place
where you can store data and compute
what I think makes the cloud really
exciting is it's is its capabilities in
terms of platform so what do I mean by a
platform here it's a set of services
that cloud providers operate that you
can access by our api's and therefore
integrate into your applications which
may run either locally or remotely you
know either on the cloud or on your own
computer to do things that would be very
perhaps difficult for you to do locally
so I guess the storage services we've
already talked about already have a sort
of a platform characteristic if I want
to write an application that runs on my
in my lab and stores all the data coming
off my instruments into a object store
and while indexing them in a racial
database I can do that via a simple
Python script that calls suitable cloud
storage api's but the the services that
we described in this slide and the next
one that allow us to do a lot
more than simply store a bit data so let
me say just say a few words about each
of them so there's a variety of data
analytic services you know some of these
simply things that let you run MapReduce
computations or spark spark computations
so computations that perform parallel
analyses of large quantities of data
there are other services like Google
Cloud Data Lab Amazon athina analytics
that provide more sophisticated built-in
analytic capabilities there's a very
rich set of services offered by various
providers that deal with data streaming
you know so data coming off a scientific
instrument - you might set up a
streaming service that would receive the
each image as it is produced and then
does something with it
you know perhaps processes that stores
the results in the in the database
notifies people that it's available
those are the sorts of things that one
can now implement very easily using
things like Google dataflow Kefka
Kinesis from Amazon and other social
services and they say yeah bit more
about that later if it point limits and
then there's a growing set of very
powerful machine learning services being
provided by absolutely all of the major
cloud providers and I think this is a
particularly exciting set of
capabilities for various reasons in
particular because the good machine
learning often requires access to
powerful computing capabilities
specialized capabilities like GPUs
graphical processing units large amounts
of data large quantities of computing
and these are all easily accessible
of course for it for a price never
needless to say on these commercial
cloud providers and they also come
provide those computing resources along
with pre-configured software to that
implement various machine learning
methods and apparently that's it's
possible because there is such a rich
collection of open source software for
various forms of machine learning deep
learning and other similar techniques
nepali because these cloud be ended see
this as differentiated so they're
constantly competing to try and offer
the best set of the software on their
platforms so you know down the bottom I
just described briefly one of the
services that amazon offers offers no it
has a pre-configured virtual machine
image which implements a variety of
different ami by the way as Amazon
machine image so they have a deep
learning ami which includes a whole
range of different platforms lots of
examples and so forth and so we can
fairly quickly run through and apply
some of these these methods so you know
one of the notebooks that we supply
number 21 we we use this to see what
happens when we try and apply a pre
trained model a model that's been
trained on a large publicly available
image in it the data set that they
decide is called image net to some
biological images so I run go through
all of the code it's only 50 lines or so
of code that sets the soxhlet loads in
the image net data at loads in the image
net to model and then we apply this to
four images that we
fed to the resulting model and so with
the single Watson yeast the bacteria and
amoeba and the seahorse and then you
know we're not just we're taking the
pre-trained model that's been trained on
public data it isn't particularly
specialized for biology but nevertheless
you'll see you know they come up with a
set of labels for these images along
with their some measure of their
confidence and when you see the top
rating for each of them is actually
correct so they all do well the yeast
and seahorse their confidence is less
high but nevertheless it does show you
that will fly essentially no effort on
it's possible to apply some quite
sophisticated machine learning
techniques to to data I mean I could be
running this labeling system on data
coming out of a lab and sometimes it
might provide some some useful
capabilities of course we if we were
doing this seriously we'd look for other
versions of this network there to be
trained perhaps with more logic one of
these are more biologically relevant
data
nevertheless some we can do very well
just out of the gate now
then we mentioned something else that I
think is important about cloud computing
and this is how one may develop
applications for for cloud platforms so
we've seen them you know I talked
briefly about virtual machines shown how
you stand up a virtual machine this
virtual machine can contain just a you
know the software that you would
normally run on your workstation it
might you know ran an application that
simply reads in some data apply some
data analytics function to it and writes
out the results and that is basically
doing what we would do at home but doing
it in the cloud instead of locally we
might be doing that for reasons of
scalability or or access to specialized
own resources but increasingly people
are developing applications on the cloud
in a rather different manner and I think
it's important to understand that if you
start thinking about using cloud for for
your own purposes and what they're doing
is building what people call cloud
native applications and this picture
down here really shows what's and what's
involved so on the Left we have you know
how we might build an application on a
desktop perhaps or you can or on the
cloud you have a set of virtual machines
or containers each of which has some
data in it in some computing logic and
you know they do whatever our data
analytic or other computations that we
want to perform so these are systems are
what we call stateful each of these
virtual machines has its own local file
system in which it's storing data if it
wants to communicate data to another
virtual machine perhaps it writes it to
a shared file system or sins of the
message or something but reliability of
these sorts of applications is
potentially challenging because of
course if your virtual machine fails
then you've you've lost the data that
was stored in it so that's not ideal a
cloud native application will typically
be structured in this sort of format all
state you know the the data you are
analyzing the results of an analysis and
so forth are stored in some cloud
storage service and these are you know
designed to be highly reliable they'll
replicate data across multiple
geographic regions they'll maintain
multiple copies of
the data and they'll keep track of which
copies are up to date and so forth and
then the computation is performed by
stateless computation stateless services
that might get created just for the
purpose of performing your analysis if
they fail no problem you simply rerun
the analysis and this has a number of
advantages it's the resulting systems
are more a more reliable they can also
be more easily scaled up and down you
know as the amount of computation that
needs to be performed changes over time
so I have a this is a quite an old
example that I still think it's a very
good one this is the the structures used
by an application or any motor I don't
know if any of you have heard of it it's
a system that takes a set of slides or
saw in pictures and creates a little
music video with the pictures that you
provide to it so no scientific interest
but in a sense it's not a typical of
many data analysis applications and
science you've got some input images you
do some processing of them then further
processing you've done the analysis you
can the state rendering and then you
distribute the results perhaps you know
could be pushing the data to a public
repository or or making it available to
people in some other way
and this is implemented as say is a
cloud native application so all space is
stored in an object store the Amazon s3
object store and there's a set of
virtual machines varying numbers of them
over time that handle things like
interact upload data upload the analysis
the rendering and distribution if
nothing is happening maybe no virtual
machines are associated or perhaps
one of each as load increases then more
virtual machines are provided you'll see
Ament reference here to a service called
Amazon Amazon sqs this is the simple
queuing service which is one of a number
of similar services operated by
different cloud providers that basically
there's what what you would think it
operates a queue into which you know
requests to do things can be placed and
from which say a virtual machine can rip
and extract elements so cloud native is
as I said increasingly the way that
people build applications so if you
simply want to analyze some data of your
own you're not going to be particularly
concerned about cloud native but if you
want to create a service that will
analyze lots of data for lots of people
then you might well want to structure
that as in the in the form that I've
just shown you and you know this is
increasingly easy to do given the
capabilities that are operated offered
by the various cloud providers one
interesting step beyond cloud native is
is what people call function as a
service so you know in the example I
just showed you we have these virtual
machines you create the virtual machine
it runs some basic logic you know wait
for a task to be available do some
computation store the result back into
into into storage that's right wrong way
in what's called function as a service
the whole need to create and manage
these virtual machines is automated so
that all one most has to do is simply
specify a function that you want to have
executed when certain events occur and
so for example here is a simple easy
simple example misses a function
responds to events messages appearing on
this system I mentioned briefly earlier
Kinesis so this you know the event might
be that a new images available from an
instrument in your lab we're using it
Kinesis for this purpose that I go on
and each time a such an event happens
we've configured this function so that
it will be executed being passed the
details of the event and some context
and the you know need to read the
details but what you'll see it does is
it on it reaches inside the event grab
some information and then loads it into
a database a dynamo DB database so 15
lines or so of code I've specified what
needs to happen whenever data or its
processed is generated by an instrument
in my lab and I don't need to be
worrying about managing virtual machines
or scaling up the number of virtual
machines and so forth I just need to
specify the function okay
getting to I've got sort of one more
topic I want to cover in the wrap-up so
one of the things that we as scientists
can do with with cloud is to use it to
provide services to others you know to
other scientists and that my group at
Chicago does this we offer a operator
service called Globus which provides
some capabilities for research data
management and specifically I show here
two of them the ability team to manage
the transfer of data from for example a
sequencing center to cloud storage or to
your institutional storage and then
manage who's allowed to access that data
sharing of that data and this Globus
software is actually a cloud native
service it runs on Amazon so every time
you make a request to it that there's a
message gets queued and in a similar
fashion to what I showed a few minutes
ago was DQ'd I transfers negotiated and
managed as and
and tracked as it receives we specify if
you request that certain data be shared
with other people and similar various
tables will be updated to reflect the
fact that some other users of that was
allowed to access your data the layer
itself doesn't need to go near the cloud
it's just the control logic that runs
very reliably and securely on Amazon
because that's what cloud platforms are
good for and like any other cloud
service is a web interface which looks a
bit like this but there's also Python
api's so you can say that I want to move
data from one computer to another by
using the submit transfer request and
then waiting for it to complete that is
what I want to do okay so that is a very
brief review of cloud computing and why
it matters for data science so just to
remind you the cloud is you can view it
as a virtual computer where you can
manage data and perform computing you
can also view it as a platform that you
can link into your own applications that
you can use to build new sorts of
applications that perform things like
that their analytics management of
streaming data and machine learning data
movement and so forth without having to
deploy a lot of complex software on your
own local computers so why therefore
does the cloud matter for data science
well these are my the the reasons that
occurred to me you may have others it
certainly provides you with
and on-demand computing and storage of
course it comes at a price you have to
pay for these services but for many
computing applications the costs and
modest relative to the time that you
might spend meeting those costs in other
ways you can get access to specialized
hardware certainly graphical processing
units and so forth what I find most
exciting of course is this rich
collection of platform services that let
you build new classes of applications
for example using this cloud native
programming model and you can do these
things in a way that achieves
scalability high availability but you
will read occasionally about events when
the cloud service has become
inaccessible but that's their only news
because they're so rare there's
certainly more available than any
computing platform that I have access to
yet any institution or lab that I might
work with and and similarly for security
you've got very complex and
sophisticated systems in place to manage
the security of these platforms and
recently people are using them in fact
to manage data and and so forth and
finding that works well for them okay so
I think that's my last slide so thank
you very much for your attention thank
you so much and that was a great
overview of cloud computing and why
should
excuse-me matter for data science a
couple of I would like to ask folks who
are listening in so if you do have any
questions for dr. Foster to please
submit them by the question of
submission system and I'll do my best to
get to them one question that we had you
mentioned it sort of at the end there I
think it's probably worth some further
thoughts from you is the notion of
security and whether you know just at a
time kind of when people are getting
used to the notion of cloud computing we
starting to see some sort of bad
examples of you know potential security
issues I know there was a issue with a
couple of things but they
by the terms of meltdown and Spectre
which sounds you know terrible what sort
of implications do these types of things
and other security issues have for
compete cloud computing and people's and
institutions I guess comfort with it
well those are good questions
I mean my view is in general that you
know a cloud computing platform is going
to be more secure than any institutions
computing platform simply because there
are more more or more people more highly
trained people you know more
sophisticated people managing security
in a place like Amazon there are there
are you know these recent events that
you mentioned they certainly of concern
I think their concern for anyone using
whoops you know what happened there
anyone who's using computers anywhere I
think the I'm sure the cloud vendors are
on top of them there are new versions of
I should also mention you know there are
different levels of security in the
cloud there are some of the things that
one has to worry about in your in your
local computers you also have to worry
about there you have to make sure that
you're running you know the right the
latest version of software that's
important there are different levels of
different example Amazon runs you know
the regular cloud and also dove cloud
which is designed for highly secure data
that example can't leave the country and
so you also need to be aware of what the
capabilities are that that they make
available to you
of course so you're based in parts at
Argonne National Laboratory which I
presume is involved in a lot of
atom-smashing and and other sorts of
particle physics and and other types of
things and I imagine that you've got a
lot of experience in examples of physics
and astronomy and possibly working with
CERN and other major organizations
looking at you know either the very
small or the very distant maybe you
could say a couple of comments on that
and what's kind of come out of some of
your interactions with those folks and
also if you've been doing any stuff
that's has biomedical relevance that
people might be interested in hearing
about well so it's looking particularly
at a time on there's we want one of one
thing will we want one area that we
spend a fair bit of time owners is
working with specialized experimental
facilities like the Advanced Photon
Source which high-energy x-ray source it
runs a number of beam lines a number of
which are specialized for biomedical or
biological applications crystallography
tomography other methods and
increasingly you know they're finding
that they they need high performance
computing or at least on-demand
computing to to enable instantaneous
analysis of data as it is collected
rather than as used to be the case you
know sending the data home on a USB
Drive or I guess floppy disk in the old
days and so we're finding that they need
these sorts of computing models that I
was talking about here and in fact we're
starting to use a mix of cloud services
to manage and dispatch computations and
and then high performance computing
facilities that are gone to actually do
the data reduction the data analysis and
so forth
a number of these you know increasingly
have a sort of a machine learning
component to them perhaps for detecting
errors or labeling data and so we're
finding that computing facilities that
are on are starting to evolve from
something that things that have been
focused almost exclusively on simulation
to increasingly being used for data
analysis learning and so forth that's
one of the reasons why we recently
established the data science and
learning division
which we're just setting up at the
moment which will be focused on those
sorts of applications oh that's great
one thing that someone had asked about
is when you were discussing the encode
project you mentioned something about
the beady bags and the the baggage
methodology you care to elaborate a
little bit more on that and kind of when
is there some easy way to know when you
might want to use that yeah so this is
something that came out of the BD bag
stands for big data bag and I think well
maybe we don't need to look at the slide
but one of the slides showed us
exchanging data between phases of a
computation using this notation it's
it's a set of conventions that
originally came out of the library
community the so called baguette
specification it's it's a very
lightweight set of rules and functions
for bundling up a some data and
associated metadata all in terms of
files and a defined file system
structure and using a JSON format to
represent metadata checksums and others
such information we developed this in
collaboration with people at USC and we
find that you know whenever we have
a computation that involves multiple
phases where one phase we might want to
run produce some data and then perhaps
run the other phase later or on a
different computer it's works well to
bundle up the results in the speedy bag
format and we've got some some nice
tools have been now been developed by
the community or managing these bags for
checking the integrity of the data room
and using the check sums for retrieving
elements of a BD bag when the contents
not the actual file but a URL we have
galaxy tools for accessing and loading
pipeline tools for accessing for
processing data are contained in these
mini bags so an we're almost at the end
of our time here but I want to give you
a minute or two here just to kind of
forecast where you see grid and cloud
computing in the next five years will we
be like dispensing with doing local
computing all together and just shipping
it out to the ether or do you see any
alterations that's how's it going to
change our lives in the next five years
yeah I think that's a good question so
the of course will still have academic
computing centers but they will perhaps
be more focused on the very high end
simulations that and other computations
they can't be performed on cloud
computing platforms I think you know
particularly for smaller institutions
they need to be you know looking very
hard at where does it make sense to
compute locally versus remotely and you
know looking at moving sort of a full
cost analysis and also trying to
understand the trade-offs involved in
you know having to maintain and and then
compete for time on a
loaded local system versus me now to
reach out to a cloud service but then
you know the other I think that area
where we hopefully will see great
progress is in the services that are
operated on cloud platforms for
scientists we're seeing a you know a
growing number of these but I think we
can go much further
prep the cloud in one form or another
will hopefully be the place where we can
process you know the data about millions
of patients that starting to become
available from various programs in the
US and abroad it's seems impractical to
imagine every institution setting up the
machinery required to you know collect
to create a copy of million genomes and
analyze them but a central cloud hosted
facility could feasibly be used for that
purpose well we'll look forward to that
time but we've reached the end of our
time though today and I'd like to thank
dr. Ian Foster from the University of
Chicago and Argonne National
Laboratories once again for telling us
why the cloud matters for data science
and I want to thank everybody who joined
us today for tuning in to the big data
to knowledge guide to the fundamentals
of data science once again thank you
everyone thank you dr. Foster and
everybody have a wonderful extra-long
weekend and we'll see you again for the
next bd2k guide to the fundamentals of
data science next week thanks everybody
take care